citizens of the reject nation i just
just just finished she-hulk episode 1
and i'm thinking that might lead to a
pseudo-sequel to world war hulk a lot
more like the world war hulk comics and
that in turn might lead directly into
secret wars i'm going to break that down
but first i want to ask you guys to
leave a like subscribe also please do
leave a comment below because i love
reading what you folks want to hear more
about you guys help inform all sorts of
stuff and i am now trying to convince
greg to let me do 18 more x-men casting
videos because of all your comments
we'll break him you keep commenting you
want to hear about gammon rogue i think
you do as we see in she-hulk episode 1
we not only get a secarian ship but it's
described as the zakarian courier ship
as in it delivers a message so with the
sakarian class a courier craft and then
hulk saying i'm gonna go deal with that
what does that mean for what i think
leads to world war hulk also please
follow me on tik tok if you want to hear
more rapid 15 second to three minute
news all sorts of casting ideas all
sorts of theories my tick tock is chock
full of that goodness you can get every
day but let's talk about hulk right
now so i've heard some theories about
scar coming onto this show a lot of
people are theorizing that since this is
a family show about the cousins jennifer
walters and bruce banner and i love
their chemistry so far that as we expand
the world of family out maybe we'll go
back and explore bruce banner's father
maybe we'll go the other direction and
explore bruce banner's son now bruce
banner son scar comes out of the world
war hulk storyline which was pretty much
adapted in a different way during thor
ragnarok we very much had warrior hulk
we very much had a lot of those elements
but we didn't have the titan that is a
violent and dangerous hulk and we didn't
have hulk ruling over anything but we
did get a lot of elements from that
story in a very visual setting i think a
lot of people especially fans of hulk
want to see a
wild and reckless and violent and
tempestuous hulk again and i think the
way we might do that is by having scar
come into the fold or maybe through the
ship which we just saw in shield there's
something with grand master maybe grand
master's like i need my warrior uh and
maybe it's a hologram or maybe it's jeff
goldblum in episode two i don't know but
i could see him being wanting his
champion again he could be trying to
bring his champion back and maybe he
alludes to scott maybe jeff goldblum's
like hey we need you back on the planet
blah blah there's some teeth i i'm
thinking something in that vein but i
think either way by the end of episode
two there's a reason that hulk is off
planet i think we're gonna get something
like age of ultron where it ends with a
cliffhanger with hulk but this time it's
smart hulk flying the ship instead of
dumb hulk being on the chip i think
there's going to be a mirror between
she-hulk and age of ultron especially
with that iron man helmet with age of
ultron but i'm i'm really curious how
that lands and i think what does go from
there is the universal rights and i mean
by that by the studio not the universal
but like the universal studios rights to
hulk apparently expire in 2023. what if
we get a solo hulk movie in 2024 what if
at d23 we see that phase five banner and
they insert another movie they could
easily it's digital you could literally
just have that up on the board your
powerpoint presentation and then kevin
feiking himself is like oh by the way we
got a couple more dates for you papa we
get a world war hulk movie or it could
be in phase six but i do think it's
gonna be in phase five and here's why in
the comic books there's the storyline
called future imperfect in this
storyline an older hulk called maestro
is
kind of folded into the reality of
battle world by doctor doom and he
serves as a baron for doctor doom i
think it'd be really interesting if
something happens to hulk his lover his
son someone dying that makes him fully
rage again he's already lost the
inhibitor band he's already lost you
know the thing that's keeping him in
control what if in this reality we break
hulk and he becomes our pseudo-maestro
and then he works with doom in secret
wars what if we have this alternate
reality hulk be our reality hulk we've
had smart hulk for a long time and
episode one strongly alluded to captain
america's a virgin hulk smashes what if
hulk smashed some alien and got a kid
out of it and those people die leading
him to lose his [ __ ] go into a rage
hulk's always wanted a family we've set
this up in age of ultron with the black
widow storyline i'm not as big on that
storyline i never really felt like the
black widow hulk thing worked for me
that way i always felt like it was more
hawkeye but that's another whole video
but i do feel like we've seen that bruce
banner wants a family so we've got that
set up right there we then maybe find
out that he did have a family and they
died that leads him to a rage we've set
up in this first episode of shield how
much he values control how much he
values those years put together to keep
the other guy at bay and to merge those
two worlds together what if without his
inhibitor and then at this great cost
everything shatters and we get an angry
hulk again now that would be hard on
earth right that'd be hard on our planet
because we've established the avengers
as a force for good we've established
hulk as a force for good but remember
that feeling when you saw the hulk
rampage in avengers but on a planetary
scale what if we do this and it's a full
planet-wide hulk madness smash and no
one's there to control him what who's
gonna stop the hulk on this planet who's
gonna calm him down who's gonna sing him
a lullaby what if hulk takes over this
planet what if hulk becomes the maestro
we next see him interacting with our
heroes in secret wars as a right hand of
doom i think this solves a lot of
people's problems with a smart hulk i
think this solves a lot of people's
problems with how marvel's handled the
hulk and i think it gives us a worthy
reason to have a solo film i think it
gives us a worthy reason in the greater
tapestry of the mcu if you've got
she-hulk as the avenger hole why not
have hulk as his original villain
himself now the things i'd want to see
in that are shades of mr fixit i would
personally love if he goes gray when he
comes back we've never gotten the grey
hulk i would love to see either a gray
or even the red hulk but that i think
that deserves to be thunderbolt ross i
think that deserves to be the earthbound
thunderbolt but gray hulk on this other
planet and you could tell some other
storylines you couldn't tell when mixed
up with the avengers again this solves
the team hulk problem versus the solo
hook problem and it ties into storylines
that work for secret wars before i give
you some comic book recommendations what
do you think about this idea do you want
a solo hulk film do you want hulk to
break bad and be evil again do you want
to see hulk as a tyrant ruling over a
planet and do you want to see hulk with
his family and all these elements and do
you think that will all lead to secret
wars let me know you think in the
comments below but first comic books i
got some recs for you i've been reading
you guys missed these recommendations
they are back i've got some for you now
world war hulk is the obvious one it
deals with a lot of the story lines
we're talking about here i think it's
pretty much a must-read if you're going
to be diving into this storyline that's
going to give you a lot of context but i
would also recommend you check out the
future imperfect storyline that's going
to give you the maestro character that
leads into him being the baron of doctor
doom in secret wars that is how i think
we're going to insert this movie into
the greater tapestry of the mcu plus
it's a very good comic so check out
future imperfect and read up on maestro
which is what i think we might lead into
with our current bruce banner hulk i
would also as ever check out the
immortal hulk now this is gonna deal
with the psychology of hulk this is the
character as a demon of sorts this is a
character working through his own inner
demons because the hulk has not just the
hulk not just bruce banner but in this
world he's got a lot of different
personalities that he's working through
and it's a very psychologically driven
comic book and i think if you've got a
solo hulk movie at this point in the mcu
15 years in annoying the character you
need to look at the psychology so i
think they could not necessarily adapt
immortal hulk because i don't see that
translating but i do think they can use
some pieces of it some voices some green
doors some elements of it that are gonna
tie into that world very well and then
most of all i think mr fixit might come
into play this is one of my favorite
hulk personalities he is gray he's
actually a bouncer out in vegas some of
the time he works with wolverine some of
the time but his cunning is in his
intelligence so he's not as strong of a
fighter as hulk but he's a better
fighter than hulk because he uses his
strength consciously and i think that's
how they'll handle a different evolution
of how hulk comes back i think if we
need to have hulk break bad it needs to
be with purpose it needs to be more it
needs to be an evolution i think they
could lean on some mr fixit storylines
some smart hulk storylines evolving into
the rage monster i would check out hulk
324 that's the first appearance of mr
fixit and also just check out some of
the fun uh wolverine mr fixit stuff just
you can get a take on that character
he's kind of like a a mafia hulk which
is just fun so check out all of that get
to read in some comic books let me know
what you think of those comic book
recommendations if you read them let me
know what your journey was like and
again thank you for welcoming me to
reject nation i love doing these videos
for you guys we will see you next time
leave a comment below from what you want
to see next
good to see you always a pleasure okay
bye
[Music]